[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you, Judy, for your
introduction and your kind
words, and to all of you for
your presence here today.
I feel extremely grateful
to Radcliffe and the Harvard
Scholar at Risk Program for
giving me the opportunity
to find an intellectual
sanctuary where
I can feel safe.
I feel truly honored
to be here and being
able to share with
you my concerns
about the fight
against corruption
and the future of my country.
When I was starting to
become a lawyer in Guatemala,
I dreamed that someday
I will be able to do
a post-graduate studies
in a foreign country.
But never in my wildest dreams
I imagine that one day I
will be a scholar at Harvard.
So being a fellow
at Radcliffe makes
me feel that life has
been very generous to me.
For a Guatemalan woman,
having a college degree
is a great achievement
since the opportunities
to go to university
are very limited.
Only 2% of the
population is able to go
to university, and a
fraction of tenths of degree.
So I consider myself extremely
privileged for the learning
opportunities that I have had.
Serving my country
as a judge was
the best way to
show my appreciation
for that privilege.
Nelson Mandela
said that education
is the most powerful
weapon which you
can use to change the world.
He argued that education
is the great engine
of personal development.
It is through education that
the daughter of a peasant
can become a doctor, that
the son of a mine worker
can become the head of the mine,
that the child of a farmers
worker can become the
president of a great nation.
It is what we make out of what
we have, not what we are given,
that separates one
person from another.
I do believe that if
you have the opportunity
to grow and develop
your skills, you also
have the responsibility
with your community
to contribute to build a
better country so others
can have the same
opportunities that I had.
During this presentation,
I will give you
some highlights and general
information about Guatemala.
Then I will present some facts
about the judicial system,
and the role of the
International Commission
Against Impunity,
known as [INAUDIBLE].
At last, I will
elaborate the challenges
that my country face in order
to become a true democracy.
Located at the center of
the American continent,
Guatemala has a strategic
location for business
and exchange of goods.
It is known as the
country of eternal spring,
since the weather is
70 degrees all year
round in the central region.
It is the perfect land for
growing any kind of crops
since there is a variety
of microclimates.
There's also beautiful scenery.
Guatemala has a wide, diverse,
and multicultural population.
It is one of the countries
in the region with one
of the largest assessment
of ethnic groups.
Most of them are
descendant of the Mayans.
Each community has its
own custom and languages.
In Guatemala, there are 24
different spoken language
in total.
We have a rich history,
great archaeological sites,
and many beautiful
places to visit.
If we didn't have
security problems,
Guatemala could sustain itself
just with the tourist industry.
It could be the perfect place
for any kind of vacation
or to relax.
But despite its
beauty, Guatemala
is one of the most violent
country in the region.
Last year, the rate of murders
was 35 per 100,000 inhabitants.
The level of impunity is 98%.
So as all you can
imagine, it is really
a paradise for
criminal activities,
causing many violations
of human rights.
This is what happened in
Guatemala almost every day.
The economy of
Guatemala is something
that I also would like to
show you in very short.
The gini is one of the
highest in Latin America, 55.
And the income per capita
is only $5,200 a year.
Guatemala's population
is about 50 million.
But more than half of the
population are indigenous.
And they are the
ones more exposed
to poverty and extreme
poverty, creating
an environment of not
only monetary inequality,
but also racial issues.
Many people consider Guatemala
to be a poor country.
I think it is not true.
It is a country with
lots of potential
that has been plundered
by terrible rulers who
usually become millionaires
after being power.
Politicians usually get
together in political parties
to take advantage of the
institutional weakness
and promote
corruption, which has
brought the country to the
worst institutional crisis
in its history.
Public safety is an
issue of greatest concern
to Guatemala's citizens.
And almost no
family that has not
been a victim of different
type of violence.
For me, personally it's
extremely difficult
to forget the day
more than 10 years ago
when I had planned to go to
the beach for a long weekend.
I had to stop at the
bakery to buy bread.
While I did, I left four of my
kids in the car with a nanny.
Suddenly, two man
entered the bakery.
One pointed a gun to the
lady that sold the bread.
And the other approached me.
He placed a gun in my
stomach and asked me
for the keys of my car.
I had left the keys in the car.
The engine was on.
So I told him to get the key,
my kids out of the car first,
and beg him not to hurt him.
It was the most terrifying
moment in my life.
But I thank God that all my kids
were safe, and also the nanny,
and it was only a bad incident.
Many of these things that
citizens in a country where
there is freedom and
peace can do normally
are very risky
situations in Guatemala.
Ordinary activities that do
as part of your normal life
are there life threatening, like
riding a bus, riding a bicycle,
talking in the cell
phone meanwhile you
walk or meanwhile
you're in the phone.
It is common to see heavy
armed guards in the streets,
in supermarkets, in bakeries,
pharmacies, movie theaters.
There are more private guards
than policemen in Guatemala.
But this is another topic
that I will not address today.
Middle and upper class citizens
live in closed neighborhoods,
like the ones we see here.
Usually, they live in
closed neighborhoods closed
by high walls, bars, and
razor wire that resembles more
a ghetto than a neighborhood.
The robbery of cell phones
is an epidemic problem.
Every member of my family has
been assaulted at least once.
Before my older son
was 18 years old,
he had been robbed
three times at gun point
in the middle of the day.
In every case, the thieves
were younger than him.
And all they wanted
was his cell phone.
One of the most dangerous
jobs in the country
is to be a bus driver
or a taxi driver
because the guns can kill you
if you aren't willing to pay
the fee of extortion.
If you are a user of
the public transport,
and happens to be
in the bus, you also
have a high chance
to be assault. Let's
look at the statistics.
In our report about the
violence in the human rights
situation from
January to June 2015,
131 persons related to
the transport service
had been killed.
This is something
to worry about.
So there is no
doubt that Guatemala
is one of the most violent
countries in the region.
According to the United
Nations, the Central America
northern triangle is the worst
second most violent region
behind South Africa.
We cannot ignore that the
country suffered internal armed
conflict the lasted 36 years.
The war left our region with a
legacy of different structures
that were built
during the period
to insure impunity,
corruption, and violence.
And they're still
operating today.
I do believe that all
Guatemalans have wounds
from the war.
The Civil War ended in
1996 with the signature
of the peace accords.
But the agreements
haven't been honored.
So after almost 20 years
of the signature of peace,
as a society we have the
same problems or worse
than before the war that
started more than 50 years ago.
As a consequence of the violence
and the lack of opportunities,
thousands of people
migrate to other countries
looking to have a better life.
Last year, the migration
of kids without parents
to the border of
the United States
was declared as an origin
humanitarian situation
by President Barack Obama.
Being forced to
leave your country
is one of the most painful
situations to face in life.
For Guatemalans
and many Hispanics,
the ties to the family,
the land, and their culture
are very strong.
When you decide to
leave your community,
you do it because there
is no other choice.
I think is not easy to
understand why a family would
send their kids to a
strange country facing
any kind of threats
in the journey.
So maybe a story
about a boy named
Angel can help us
understand what is happening
in the Central American region.
So I want you to meet Angel.
Last July, meanwhile
many Guatemalans
were in the streets claiming the
government to stop corruption
and asking the
president to resign,
Angel was fighting for his life.
A gang kidnapped
Angel from his school.
The days after, he was found
at the bottom of a deep ravine.
Incredible, he survived.
He told his family
that the gang wanted
to force him to kill a bus
driver as a rite of initiation.
Angel was not a violent kid.
Actually, he was a
very good student.
The gang members probably
didn't knew that Angel's father
was a bus driver.
Angel refused to kill anyone.
So the gangster
decide to kill him.
But they gave him two options--
either to be dismembered,
or thrown at the ravine.
He chose the last one.
The day after, he
was found alive.
But the story doesn't end here.
The firemen that rescue him
took him to a public hospital.
As usual in Guatemala,
there were no medicines.
So his father had to go and buy
medicine and sterilize water
for the doctors to be
able to cure his words.
In the meantime, Angel died.
As a Guatemalan
journalist pointed out,
this 12-year-old boy was killed
twice-- one by the violence,
and the other by a system
marked by corruption.
So maybe this can help us
understand why the parents are
willing to send their
kids away, because this
is what their they're facing.
As we all know, governments
have certain obligations
toward their citizens.
Among these, they should
guarantee security and justice
for all.
If the institutions that are in
charge of this important task
do not do their job,
then the rule of law
is an empty concept.
Guatemala is a clear example
of a weak state where
the correlation between
corruption, weak institutions,
impunity, and violence has a
clear impact in human rights
violations of different kinds.
Since we live in an era of
globalization, and in many ways
we are related, this affects
other states as well.
Martin Luther King said that
injustice anywhere is a threat
to justice everywhere.
We are caught in an inescapable
network of mutality tied
in a single garment of destiny.
Whatever affects one directly,
affects all indirectly.
I do believe that the
words of Martin Luther King
are true today.
The effects of impunity
and constant violation
of human rights in
one small country
can affect the stability
of its neighbors.
According to our research done
by a foreign policy magazine,
one of the three most
important foreign policy
issues facing the
United States today
is the issue failure
or failing states.
Guatemala has a long
history of good relations
with many nations that
have tried to help
the country in different ways.
For example, the sign
of the peace agreement
was possible thanks
to the mediation
of the international community.
The European Union has
spent millions of Euros
in different projects to help
build better institutions.
The United States has a program
called the Central American
Regional Security
Initiative, known as CARS.
This program focuses on the
rule of low promotion, police
professionalization, and poverty
reduction in Central America.
But it seems that despite all
the help that we have received,
nothing has changed since 1980
when the program was launched.
So in 2006, 10 years after the
sign of the peace agreements,
the violence claim as much
lives as the civil war did.
The high levels of impunity
force the Guatemalan government
to ask the United
Nations for help
in the fight against corruption.
So the International Commission
Against Impunity in Guatemala
was created.
This is what the former
Vice President Stein said.
We realized that we couldn't
fix our institution alone.
We figured that if member
states could ask the Security
Council for
peacekeepers, why not
help to address an
internal problem that
is as serious as
war, organized crime.
This new institution from the
United Nations, know as CICIG,
was conceived as
an independent body
to support the Public Prosecutor
Office, the National Police,
another state institutions
in the investigation
of sensitive and
difficult cases.
The ultimate goal is
that through CICIG work,
national judicial
sector institutions
will be strengthened,
and be able to confront
illegal groups and organized
crime in the future.
According to CICIG,
there are certain things
that the government
of Guatemala has
to do in order to
build the capacity
to fight against
impunity and corruption.
One of those recommendation
is independence of judges.
And that is something I would
like to tell you more about
and share my personal
experience in this manner.
As a judge, I have
always been protective
of the judicial independence.
I do believe that it is the
keystone of any republic
and democratic system.
I am also convinced that
through the proper application
of justice most of our
conflicts can be solved,
and we as a community can
achieve the freedom and peace
that we all desire.
But in Guatemala
history, there has never
been independence
of the judiciary
from other branches of
power, the executive
or the legislative.
And nowadays, we have organized
crime, corrupt politicians,
and even law firms trying
to influence the judiciary.
So the goal to build
a stronger institution
and gain judicial
independence is something
that the judges have
to build and insist on.
On this regard,
Stephen Breyer said
that, ultimately, independence
is a matter of custom, habitat,
and institutional expectation.
To build those customs,
habits, and expectations
require time and support, not
only from the bench and bar,
but from the communities
where the judges serve.
Unfortunately, it
may prove easier
to dismantle that independence
than to obtain it.
That was the case during the
[INAUDIBLE] process of election
from magistrates from the
Appeals and Supreme Court
last year in Guatemala.
I think it's necessary to
tell you that in my country
there's a clear difference
between being a judge
and being a magistrate.
A judge usually are
appointed in the lower
courts, which are called
Peace Courts or First Instance
Courts.
They are named after a
long process of selection
by opposition that
requires a person
to prove their
knowledge, capacity,
and ability to become a judge.
Then he or she will have to
go to the School of Judicial
Studies and be [INAUDIBLE],
previously to be appointed.
But if a judge wants to become
a magistrate for the Appeal
or Supreme Court, the
process is totally different.
First, the candidate has to go
through a process of nomination
by the nominating
committees better known
as postulation commission.
And then he or she will have
to be elected by the congress.
Every five years, there are
election for magistrates.
Many judges want to
become magistrates.
But everybody knows it is
a high political process.
And this is in the news.
And everybody knows
that the process is not
something that is very clear.
I have been a first instance
judge for almost seven years
and a substitute
magistrate for two,
and wanted to continue in
my position as a magistrate.
Therefore, last year I
participated as a candidate
to be reelected in
the Court of Appeals.
During the last election
of judges of higher courts,
there were many
claims of violation
of the constitutional law.
Different human
rights organizations
present complaints.
More than 80 lawsuits
for serious violations
took place during the process.
The commissioner from
CICIG, [INAUDIBLE],
spoke out against the
process in the selection.
The special repertoire
of independence
of judges and lawyers
of the United Nations
denouncing that the process
was against the basic principle
of independence of the
judiciary approved by the UN.
According to this principle,
the qualification selection
has to do a lot with
selection and training.
And I consider this
subject very important
because instead of appointing
the best candidates, those
with the background
experience and ability,
the court selection
process in Guatemala
has become a political game.
Therefore, what
prevails is favoritism
and the granting of
privilege to individuals
that lack values,
principles, and morals ethics
required to fulfill such
a high respected position.
Furthermore, some of
those who were appointed
are generally connected to
special interest groups and/or
to organized crime.
As Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg said,
judicial independence is
vulnerable to assault.
It can be shattered if
the society law exists
to serve does not take care
to assure its preservation.
For many judges of
lower courts, it
was clear that the whole
process of election
of judges in the higher courts
was against the Constitution,
and above all, a clear violation
against the human right
for a citizen to have an
independent and impartial
tribunal.
Even though some of us had
applied to become magistrates,
we were convinced that the
process was a fraud organized
by corrupt politicians, broke
lawyers, and also unethical
lawyers, that were
looking forward
to take the judiciary
under their control.
For me, it was the end of
our incipient democracy,
and the last step to
become a failed state.
I felt terribly disappointed.
So I decided to formulate a
legal opinion which clearly
indicate interferes with
the judicial independence
by interested groups
and parallel powers.
I always knew that
this was dangerous
and a very difficult battle.
But it was worse not to try.
I was the president
of an organization
of judges that promotes changes
inside the judicial system
called [SPEAKING SPANISH].
So I present a legal
opinion to CICIG,
to the Office of the High
Commission of Human Rights,
and later to the prosecutor
of human rights in Guatemala
in order that his office
could present a complaint
at the Constitutional Court
and override the whole process.
But, meanwhile this
happen, suddenly
on a Saturday
afternoon three days
before the election
of Courts of Appeals,
I receive a very weird message
in my Facebook from a lawyer
that I hardly remember.
This is the copy of the message
that I received that day.
It said, hello, Claudia.
I'm Vernon Eduardo Gonzalez.
We studied together in the
University Francisco Marroquin.
I need to talk about the
issue of election of judges.
It is urgent.
My cell phone is--
I was very suspicious
of the message.
But I decide to
call him and agreed
to meet alone with
[INAUDIBLE], a high rank
congressmen of the ruling
party and former president
of the congress.
During the meeting, I
find out that Gonzalez
was the attorney of the Vice
President Roxana Baldetti,
and that they had present
a petition in the court
where I serve.
In Guatemala, it's
unconstitutional for government
officials to hold position
with the political parties.
But they wanted
the court to allow
the Vice President to
serve as a secretary
of the official party.
The attorney of the Vice
President, Vernon Gonzalez,
and Congressman
Rivera offered me
to be elected as a magistrate in
exchange for a favorable ruling
to the vice president.
The congressman clearly said,
you know that in this process
it doesn't matter your
experience, your background,
your knowledge.
All that counts is
who do you know.
And now you have the chance to
have good friends in Congress.
We can help you to be elected.
But you need to give
us this resolution
in favor of the Vice President.
I was in shock.
The 30 minutes that
the meeting lasted,
I knew I was not going
to give the resolution.
But I didn't know how to react.
I knew it was going to
be the end of my career.
And I was terribly
nervous, because I
was recording the conversation
without them knowing.
At the end, I
denied the petition
in Monday, September 29, 2014.
Next day, the Congress
voted to elect me
as a magistrate for
the Appeal Courts.
But I could not accept the post
knowing that the whole process
was a scam.
Then I took the time to
talk to some judges that
were elected as magistrates.
I tried to convince
them to resign with me.
But they didn't want to.
Some of them were afraid
of the consequences.
And others preferred to
have their job secure.
I decided to resign as
an elected magistrate
and remain as a judge
in the lower courts.
When I did, I publicly
denounced all the flaws
in the process of election.
Later, a group of more than
80 judges backed me up.
And we all asked the
Constitutional Court
to void the process.
However, the judges who
support the claim immediately
received retaliation.
And the newly elected
magistrate put pressure on them
to dissuade them.
This pressure were in the form
of threats, and dismissal,
and reviews of prohibition by
the administrative [INAUDIBLE]
of the judiciary in
order to discharge them.
In the meantime,
the high officials
of governments-- the
president, the vice president,
and many of the leaders
of the political parties--
in public declarations,
refute my statement
and ask for proofs.
This was a clear interference
with the dependence
of the judiciary.
They didn't knew at
that time that I also
made a complaint before CICIG
against the lawyer Gonzalez
and the congressman Rivera on
charges of influence spending
and bribery.
Along with the complaint,
I submitted the recording
of the conversation and the
offers of those involved.
Three days after I resigned,
Guatemala Constitutional Court
decide to temporarily
suspend the swearing
of the judges of
the Supreme Court
and the Chamber of Appeals
elected for the period
2014-2019.
All members of the
Institute of the Judiciary
made every effort
we could to ensure
that Guatemala citizens
and international community
knew what was going on
in the justice system.
We went to radio, television
programs, organized forums,
interviews, and talks.
The media covered
this issue abundantly.
At international level, we
denounced the serious event
that threatened the democratic
system in our country.
We wanted the world to
know because we desperately
needed help to save our
small but beautiful country
from corruption and impunity.
I was able to go to Europe.
In Brussels, I talked to
officials of the European
Commission and also met
with human right defenders.
In Geneva, I went to the
Office of the High Commissioner
of Human Rights, the Office
of the Repertoire of Judicial
Independence.
We also went to the
Inter-American Commission
of Human Rights of the
Organization of the American
States in Washington to
file a complaint a violation
of judicial independence.
However, no effort was enough.
Given the influence
of the powers that
control the appointment
of Congress,
40 days after the
Constitutional Court decided
to suspend the
election, the court
issued a final ruling that the
allegations were unfounded.
And the courts elected
should take office.
When I realized that
there was nothing else
to do against the process
of election of courts,
I decided I was going to go back
to my post in the lower courts
and do my best as a judge.
I was aware that the
Supreme Court magistrates
were not happy with
everything that had happened,
but hoped that
they understood it
was about ethical
principles and not
a personal remark against them.
I was totally wrong.
They wear absolutely offended.
They were ready to destroy
my judicial career.
First, they didn't want
to recognize my position
as a judge.
I had to present a claim.
The prosecutor of human rights
of Guatemala had to intervene.
And, finally, they allowed
me to go back to my court.
Then they send a
supervision to my judiciary
and pressure all the officials
to press charges against me
with no reason.
This is when I realized that
my actions and initiation have
placed my family and me
in a high risk situation.
Not only my professional
career was at risk.
But I also was advised that
our physical integrity was
in jeopardy because I made clear
evident that the difference
of the executive and
the legislative power
in the election of high
judicial officials,
and had also note
further infiltration
of the parallel
powers and organized
crime in the judicial system.
The case of election
of the judges
was an alarm that all government
institutions in Guatemala
were infiltrated
by organized crime,
and also was a precedent
for what happened later
when CICIG made public the
investigation about corruption
in the executive and in
the legislative branch.
The work of the International
Commission Against Impunity
in Guatemala under the direction
of Commissioner Ivan Velasquez
has been a key player in
the history of justice
in Guatemala.
Believe me, Ivan Velasquez is
a super hero for Guatemalans.
He is.
And he also has a
great recommendation
in international level.
Yesterday, the Foreign
Policy Magazine
recognized him as one of
the most influential persons
in the world.
From April to August,
different cases of corruption
were made public after
CICIG investigations.
It was clear that the most
powerful and influential
politicians were involved.
Institutional
weakness in Guatemala,
and non-fulfillment of
duty by public officials,
have caused a constant
violation of human rights
for Guatemalans.
The current crisis is the
result of many years of abuse
by political and legal
system incapable of proving
peace and justice.
Through the investigations
carried out by CICIG,
it has been evident
why politicians
are other interested
groups manipulated
the election of judges.
They discovered the relation
between the group of lawyers
known as a legal
freedom for impunity
and its link with judges.
And here we have how
this structure works.
This picture here
is from a judge.
And this is the structure
that they discovered
that was in the scam.
And these are the lawyers.
And these are the ones
that are involved.
And this is a picture
of a Supreme Court judge
magistrate that was elected.
And this is the structure.
His son is involved in
one of the structures,
his nephew in another one.
And this lady is the same
that was before here.
And she's her sister-in-law.
So it's all tied.
OK, so this lead to
a national awakening
unprecedented in the country.
Citizens from different
sectors forgot their difference
and peacefully and
spontaneously took the streets
to express their rejection of
corruption and demand justice.
For more than eight
months, every Saturday
the Central Park of Guatemala
City was crowded by families.
I'm going to show you a video.
It was crowded by families,
students, human right
defenders, entrepreneurs,
among others.
And all of them were
demanding for a change
through peaceful protest.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHANTING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHANTING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So in August, CICIG
reported that according
to the investigation,
destruction
of the case of custom
fraud, [SPEAKING SPANISH],
was also directed by the
President of the Republic,
General Otto Perez Molina.
That created a national
strike in August 17,
the first of the
process in a weekday
where businesses, schools,
universities, and factories
were shut down.
Eventually, on September
2, the congress
lift impeachment, and leave
no immunity to the President.
So he was forced to resign.
Hours later, he
was sent to jail.
So now, it is up to
the justice system
to demonstrate that
it has the ability
to solve these problems.
Some judges of the
first instance court
are, with no doubt,
committed to justice
and to promote the rule of law.
But what will happen
with the magistrates that
were elected last year?
Will the Court of Appeals
and the Supreme Court
step away from their groups?
Or will they answer to the
so-called telephone justice
system, the one that occurs when
the party boss calls the judges
and tells them how to decide the
outcome of a particular case,
as explained by Stephen
Breyer regarding
the judicial system in Russia?
CICIG Commissioner
Ivan Velasquez
have repeatedly said
the efforts from CICIG
and the public ministry
to combat corruption
and to help the
country won't help
if the judiciary doesn't assume
its historical responsibility.
The fight against
corruption is a fight
that involves the
society as a whole.
Many years ago,
Edmund Burke said
that the only thing necessary
for the triumph of evil
is for good men to do nothing.
That means that apathy
is the enemy of justice.
But we do not want Guatemala
or any other country
to be a failed state.
I am optimistic.
And I believe that
good Guatemala citizens
will stand to make
that large scale
changes that need
to be done so we
can hope for a better future.
OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]